less than 20 until kickoff here we go
warzone rated one minute
122 players of 150 max 1765 average
rating time handicap will be adjusted
according to rating here we go Game one
of how many I have no idea hopefully a
lot with a lot of wins double the points
sicilian land
now what defy vis coming with tempo
maybe on the bishop or maybe it's not
maybe my Knights getting kicked away
back home or not okay temple gainer the
bishop where's it gonna go check a ruse
key check a ruse key defender risky
defense how to recapture with the queen
of the night I'm going with clean so the
knight could play to c6 alright knight
c6 if Knight to f3 I don't want to deal
with 95 hitting my clean open file is
the e-file let's get a rook there
challenge this Bishop the knight place
here I take all animals nut
I almost didn't take and I'm dropping
some material probably real soon I think
this is a good move I'm dropping c5 now
not so far I'm catching up a bit on time
the knight coming to this square could
be very annoying trades I want to make
sure I can maintain control over this
file if possible I have control over
that and this square right here I don't
want that night to get there there might
be King here let's back up to this
square if rook here I play f5 and that's
game over or is it actually no there'd
be a knight check watch out for the
sneaky stuff my opponent was just
getting sneaky right there and now we're
gonna have a serious amount of exchanges
coming up and in this end game who's
gonna stand better first things first
defend f5 and then King position that
took a while for my opponent to take
that why aren't they taking that sooner
my bishop can use some work this is a
good diagonal and now I'm getting ready
to play here which is made this would be
me this is me this is me back to
tournament oh no we're out of nowhere
somebody has two games in already in
four points okay Edie bogo ed Bogle I
don't think I have played mr. ed Bogle
before there is a knight takes right
here okay let's not do that
Castle this is dry take here so I get
the F file please darn it they're not
doing it all right let me take here and
I'm not sure why I did that but I'm
gonna do it I guess I'm out of pins to
get out of there bishop okay now let's
do this and okay my queen has to come
over here let's do this and then this
and there might be some sacrifice on
this square let's come here I'm a little
bit afraid of getting trapped
okay Knight get to f5 f5 is the plan
f7 is weaker because the rook is in the
corner I think it might actually be out
of play can you believe that it might
actually be out of play okay tricks
right here right here as well H file
there's a serious problem there's
probably some sac or something let's do
this rook up and over
rook up and then over oh oh oh oh wait a
second I don't want to do that I want me
there was a discovered check available
but this is I think better AJ oh it's
being defended I missed that and it's
trapped oh no oh no I'm crying now I'm
crying
definitely crying right now oh man I'm
gonna take like this I'm in trouble
I'm in some serious trouble because of
that check I got to go here I got this
rook
I got need to defend over here Queen
defend how much time how much time I'm
down on time tricky Knights I need the
tricky Knights where are they at
not moving quick enough I'm not moving
quick enough where the tricky nights
tricky nights six point seven just take
this uh just take a night please let me
get this okay can I get this my opponent
is flying how much time how much time
how much time it's there I go again hold
my breath I have no idea there's no
explanation for holding my breath but I
was just holding my breath right there
and this is the leader of the pack this
is the pack leader okay are they going
to target my h7 pun I think they're
ready to do that how can I defend okay
okay let's get this in I'm not sure why
okay let's come here let's take that and
I get that pond real quick let's go over
here and oh okay that could be cramping
maybe where does my knight want to go
right here or my rook wants to be here
what's that pawn up to I want to get rid
of that night get out of there night I'm
gonna take them oh oh are they in
trouble I just want to get this in and
they could take that pawn but maybe the
bishop gets trapped if they do that I
keep things closed a little bit over
here okay this is a little scary the
Queen in the bishop gonna get on that
diagonal my king wants to run a little
bit LightSquared control where's the
light square control I have this covered
no okay
let's open this up over here somehow for
caboose key on d3 if takes hmm
oh my queen is there to defend
fortunately huh okay there's a
disconnect over here though or is there
uh I don't have anything I don't have
anything what's the time situation it
spins and stuff what are my rooks doing
they're doing nothing
they're doing something now let's get
this guy there Rick is out of play
fortunately and I have a fort here and I
had a footwork I still have a fork oh
but there's trouble on my back rank hang
on back rank trouble give a check I
think I want to just take this bish up
oh they missed that this is good now
right here
grab this pawn come back and defend no
no no no no King King King King position
hang on
oh this is this is trouble no it's not
oh yes it is I'm down I was up a full
rook uh where did I go with my time oh
there's no recovering is there Oh 23
minutes left
can I come back don't you dare quit
there's no quit in you there's no quit
in you don't you dare to start quittin
no don't have it don't you dare start
quitting get out of there Knight Oh such
a dead man I'm dead meat I am so dead
meat Oh there's gonna be tricky stuff
right around the corner pawn push and
stuff pawn push and stuff pawn push and
stuff oh I'm a dead man that pot is
going crazy and I'm in some serious hot
water I'm so dead here oh do I have some
hope somehow come on let this work is it
working
just move why am I not moving oh man I'm
so dead ah I got nothing i got nothing
I'm so dead oh look at how I'm going
backwards
that's enough oh I'm so dead I don't
have anything this is so B you're
getting Queens and stuff
I look at the time situation can I get
the Queen I have to resign again I want
to cry back the tournament I have to I
have to usually I say I have to after
one game Oh No is there any hope is
there any hope you could do it
oh I can't do it can I somebody has 30
points it's in somebody has to and that
person's me okay don't you dare quit no
don't you dare start you're quittin okay
sack pieces now I guess I'd better be
sort of conservative yeah let's be
conservative it's only a bullet game be
conservative that's what you want to do
oh sure just open up the see file
because you're King cleaner and on it
that's a lovely thing isn't it open up
the see file because your king and queen
are really happy about that they're
gonna be thanking you later okay that's
a free pot I'm gonna take them I think
he's free I'm getting forked I'm a dead
man again
there's no saving it Queen takes pawn
Knight takes bishop pile up oh man is
this crumbling fast Oh
so dead I'm a dead man
look takes bishop and stuff oh come over
here is it safe over here just trade
Queens please there's maybe hope please
just trade Queens what did I do to
deserve this okay now it's back to
alright I think I think can I get a win
here please
pivot don't you dare give up double up
double trouble
grab cheap on grab a bishop don't move
the knight or you're dead don't you dare
move that night just in case I move the
knight let's do this let's go bishop no
time they have no time back determined I
have a guess who doesn't have a or these
is 56 42:39 let's go here let's roll ah
you could do it you could do it you
could do it I'm looking for top three
can I get a top three somehow there's
less than 20 minutes I gotta fly
my opponents ready to kill me in one
move on f2 I would have screamed get out
of there clean I can't deal with you get
out of there clean hit the bishop grab a
knight hit on f6 uh-oh
serious trouble snip a knight
f7 check a ruski no there's gonna be a
main or is there
oh this isn't me or is it I got the rook
at least oh this is mate now quick move
yes back to tournament 16 I'm in 23rd Oh
far off from top ten even why am I
thinking top three can I get this
somehow say it's possible please I need
some encouragement you can do it you can
do it let's go setting it up sort of
sort of setting it up nope
that was my little worm that was my
Nightcrawler that they just took Oh
Castle queenside the queen is mine
Castle queenside still setting it up
Castle queenside you know you want a
Castle queenside Queen side
you still want a counselor queenside you
still want a counselor queenside right
now power of suggestion no it's not
working the power of suggestion is not
working in this game okay here's the
plan
Bishop c5 followed by Queen here lights
out pin ruski queen g3 leading to me in
a few a night here no it's not working
the bishop has to play here
the knight has to play here next no this
isn't working either I could take on g7
and then pile up again if I take the
pawn recaptures in the queen defense
laterally so I want to do it in this way
oh this isn't good this is main okay
that was sort of quick they resigned -
okay 26 I'm in 15th place
93 is top dog okay 16 minutes and change
anything can happen it is a one minute
game there could be quick resign errs
where are the Clippers einar's let's
watch out for this here is there a sack
here no not quite okay well let's try
this oh there goes this okay or not they
could grab that pawn
can't they let's defend and maybe get an
f4 f5 g4 g5 stuff seems a bit reckless
but I'm gonna try it
g4 g5 queenside castle first they're
gonna take take like this open the F
file and this diagonal here we go here
we go open it up open this up right here
right now uh-oh smashing it open check a
ruski where's the mate coming up right
around the corner making one threat
resignation resigned time there's no
defense is there don't run your clock
just resign don't don't let the clock
tick okay back to term at 38 I got it
I'm in 10th okay now it's time to start
chipping away at these guys can i chip
away at them 15 minutes we're halfway
there c5 d5 launch the H pond that's
your only hope
you did it before try and do it again
pin the night and then h4 maybe and hit
my Bishop I'll back up okay it's pinned
pin Knight be scared
Oh be scared now what pin tonight still
hit the pinned piece it's the name of
the game oh oh the Queen has to run
somewhere and there she goes oh there
goes my rook if I do that let's do this
oh man I gotta get creamed queenside
castle right should probably do this
first get out of there Bishop queenside
castle I need some light square control
pawn push here's available - that's no
good just takes like this I'm on the
Queen I gotta try this this is no good
there's Forks I'm on the Queen are they
gonna see it no they blundered I got the
Queen for free okay now what Shak grab
this Bishop next and then the rook and
then this is leading to mate actually
real soon the bishop has to block I'll
play here and then it's mayn't next just
move anything quickly quickly quickly 14
minutes and change back to tournament 52
I'm in 7th 123 90-68 Jaden
efore efore for the win
this no matter what maybe Smith Tamura
okay I have a center I could push that
night away push him away maybe they'll
resign they're gonna resign quick come
on right here take the knight he's free
I got the Queen come on this is time to
resign time to resign they're not
resigning ah
come on this is so beat the kitchen sink
variation I could just take it out my
bishop they're not resigning I need
these wins quick okay I'm gonna try and
fishing pulling my opponent right here
right here and then fishing pole fishing
pole set them up the fishing pole can I
get this now
quickly don't run away King yes back to
tournament back to tournament what do we
have 68 I'm in fifth 143 110 86 85 68 Oh
13 minutes left okay they're going with
some very calm setup throw four pawns
here and why not another one
line up they're throwing their pawns up
I'm gonna throw mine hopefully get it
there King and let's get on this
diagonal somehow can this open up I want
this to open up here get that Bishop
Bishop move Bishop move coming up and
then clean out to h4 is gonna be a
killer isn't it pins and clean right
here just go right there is that gonna
be good we hit the Queen oh oh wait this
is check and then I got I got me I got
me no matter what just move just move
just move just move just move anything
uh-huh don't be a non mover okay back to
turn I got that 186 143 110 86 86 how
much time is left 12 minutes
efore let's go Bishop c4 f4 Knight f3 my
bishop has to run home because I didn't
play d3 in time and my knight has to go
home oh he is not too good for his home
f4 is falling no it's not let's go the
knight is in decent position clean side
space knight h5 hit g7o
defense I might just sack queen g3 might
hear something where's the mates hit
this pawn push here I take I got a take
I didn't have to but I want to oh my
queen is hit I got to do this and then
take the knight there's got to be
submitting some mates here real soon
though
right let's run away a little bit
oh come on move okay this is check
where's the main where's the main is
there may here please let there be a
mate is this mate where's there mate
this is mate this is made this is mate
this mate to turn
King went for a giant hike he went for a
hike 173 is probably never gonna be
caught
can I get second somehow after a
seriously poor start to losses uh get
out of there night where are you gonna
go oh he's not going anywhere I'm on the
rook I'm on the bishop oh come on come
on each pond Oh six what are you doing
with aged six they're trying to make me
an f7 ah get outta there Queen let's go
H pond what is this what's going on here
they're checking me around like crazy
Bishop takes Queen takes their are they
gonna do that it's a bad move
look right here is available pond push
open this up here get this skewer
actually double the rooks and still work
on doubling there's gonna be night move
there oh I'm losing some material but
that's alright I have a lot okay I
thought night right there is gonna be
best I'm here there's a queen check I
don't want to do it though I want to get
out h2 my knight can now go to a good
square right here but first let's get on
this diagonal and a rook check this is
gonna be legal TKO time real soon Queen
I'm just gonna take here got made
threats right around the corner right
around the corner here okay this is main
its mate back to tournament 126 130 126
243 19 games what do you do when
somebody has 19 games in whoa nowhere
close to get 19 games in how many games
do I have in uh far from nineteen okay
can I get us can I manage a second let
me do this and then
I can back my Bishop up in this
direction and then castle Queenie one
Queen g3 and f5 or actually Knight g5
would be a good one let's do this in you
know I could get to the d5 square maybe
real soon
d5 f7 is coming under some heavy fire
right now and I could get this pawn it's
a fork
there's rook here though oh boy oh oh oh
oh man oh they just gave up they're
clean I thought Knight here hitting at
g2 would be fantastic
just take my night so I could block up
this Bishop mm-hmm this is scary
Oh Knight right here is gonna be good I
think I know I could take this okay now
I could block this I'm on this Bishop
twice I'm on the rook uh-oh serious
problems now you take this and then
maybe the rook okay I have this I can
run away to f2 if there's a check
where's the main this is reasonable
seven seven minutes and change where's
the mate let's defend this that rook is
pinned bishop check me it's running away
check he's running away don't run away
where you going quit you're running away
check clean somewhere to clean right
here this is where I want to be that's
me
okay back to chairman 146 Oh 165 148 146
six minutes and change China four top
three second is the best I could
possibly do there's no catching first as
much as I would like to it's not
happening inside Castle probably coming
out where is it play Bishop d6 with play
rook here Bishop d6 if King side Castle
let's preserve my knight
position and let's get to c4 I'm getting
kicked around why is it my opponent
moving okay let's let's go here I think
that earlier pawn move would have been
the right thing Forks gotta get rid of
that and then gotta get rid of this
Knight
hopefully I'm not trapped here I can't
take with the pond otherwise I get mated
scary the Queen can't recapture on d5 if
Knight here I want to play here maybe
open up the C file target the beep on
get my Bishop to e7 would be nice if I
complete my development let's go here
and not drop my Queen more development
where is it at it's a long way off okay
I actually have rook activity now I
don't have to castle I'm on the knight
but it takes pawn I take the knight
let's come back here I could have also
pinned the night okay let's come here
I'm dropping that pond there's nothing I
can do to save it I have defense I have
two connected passed pawns let's guard
this out the second rank and it's give a
check and I guess come here next what's
the clock situation I want to trade a
pair of rooks I think one pair of rooks
and get my pawns rolling just one pair
defend like this and then get my pawns
pushed real soon all right here get them
going pawn push on push pawn push more
pawn pushes pawn push Oh
okay they're dropping stuff time time
situation okay why don't worry I where
okay I got it
185 168 160 something what do I have I
have 166 I'm two points out of third I
want that third place third place gives
me a little trophy oh what's this
what's going on here does this clean up
- pawn takes pawn I'm on the Queen on
the Queen
oh come on this is time to resign isn't
it clean here ah their kitchen sink
defense it's the kitchen sink defense
check where's the mate there might be a
smothered me if that Knight is allowed
to sit there whoa this king is getting
crazy it's definitely getting crazy here
this King okay where is the main here
looking for that mate
that nights not bother me that's me
that's me that's me back to chairman
where we at 186 I'm in third oh I could
definitely still be caught 198 can I get
second
can I keep third can I hold third oh man
doing early Queen c7 or not open
Sicilian Queen c7 h2 where is it at age
two age two where are you okay that
night can be captured probably just to
double my pawns okay coming at white
rook on the G file queenside castle here
we go the bishop and reel converging on
g2 let me do this I don't know if I even
need the queenside castle
okay I'm winning material now Bishop c5
make it more difficult to get that pawn
okay they're dropping stuff fork fork
this is a mate h2 actually the King has
to move just going the corner quickly
quickly quickly 2 minutes and 50 seconds
do not let your clock tick don't be a
clock ticker
no ok good back to term at 206 I have a
one-point lead over the guy who beat me
one of the two that beat me
this guy again the kitchen sink er I
think right it wasn't this the guy that
was throwing all his pieces at me the
bishop f2 guy yes it is this guy's back
in town can I try a similar get that
Queen again yeah it's gonna be
this time I'm on the clean it scene this
time I'm gonna get that Queen out of
there get out of there Queen she trapped
no now she's close to trapped I think
it's not working out there's a block
with the bishop for the night
I could play off three and then move the
pawn again or something I need to get
more development in though my knight
needs to come out they have less than 30
seconds this game is not gonna end it's
just gonna be a time type of thing
they're letting the clock tick kitchen
sink kitchen sink I do not want any of
my time to be burnt right here they're
gonna take that anything less than 10
can I get in one more win one more win I
need to get there's a minute 16 15 14
left in the tournament okay back to
tournament to 26 to 35 one minute eight
seconds quickly oh this guy is too old
one he's right up there
okay he's having a good tournament Queen
c7 let's go with this I'm on the night
castle H - H - H - it's easy to miss
very easy to miss I should have still
done it I'm gonna give a check it's not
really good okay that night is gonna
kill me okay maybe not
uhm let's come here oh this isn't
working
okay I gotta go in a more solid way here
pile up here pawn push Bishop c6
actually I need to do this I need to
watch some dark squares I think my queen
wants to be over here she's not getting
over there okay actually is she is
there's c4 c4 is a good move okay
endgame what do we have this isn't
finishing what do we have what do we
have I got something fatty I'll take the
confetti third please oh man not the
best but now I guess the worst from that
start oh man - 331 255 226 good games
all